a juani al aura se les pidió que
factorizar an el término 24 x a la 5
como el producto de dos monos sus
respuestas se muestran abajo y aquí
tenemos la respuesta de juan y la
respuesta de laura por ejemplo la de
juan dice 24 x a la 5 es igual a 8x
cúbica por 3 x cuadrada y la de laura
dice 24 x a la 5 igual a 4x x 6x a la
cuarta cuál de los dos estudiantes
factor hizo la expresión correctamente
muy bien entonces como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta muy bien primero vamos a ver la
respuesta de juan nos dice 24 x a la 5
es igual a 8x cúbica por 3x cuadrada
primero veamos qué ocurre con los
números muy bien entonces aquí tenemos 8
que multiplica a 3 verdad
y ponerlo así para que no se tape el
otro entonces 3 por 8 8 por 3 es lo
mismo que 24 verdad entonces hasta aquí
vamos bastante bien ahora vamos a
analizar qué ocurre con la variable x
aquí tenemos x cúbica que multiplica a x
cuadrada y x cúbica por x cuadrada en
efecto nos da de perdón x cúbica así que
la respuesta de juan es correcta ahora
veamos la respuesta de laura aquí
tenemos cuatro que multiplica a 6 y eso
en efecto nos da 24 hasta aquí va bien
laura luego tenemos x que multiplica a x
a la cuarta y x x x a la cuarta nos da x
a la 5 así que la respuesta de laura
también es correcta muy bien entonces
ambos estudiantes factorizar on la
expresión de forma correcta esto sólo
fue un ejercicio para mostrar que no hay
una forma única para factorizar un mono
mío yo podría dar otro ejemplo por
ejemplo podría ser
24 x a las 5 es igual a 12 x kubica por
ejemplo verdad y habría que
multiplicarlo porque 12 por 2 nos da 24
y x cúbica por equis cuadrada nos da x a
las 5 verdad así que aquí tenemos otra
forma posible así que claramente hay
varias formas posibles de factorizar un
mono mió en el producto de otros dos
mono mios